what's up guys my name is colin this is
the score esports and you're about to
get into the top 10 teams or players in
esports
that you love to hate now before we do
what the heck does it mean
to love to hate something well these are
the teams or players that you cheer for
when they lose but you still want to see
them compete these are the people that
because of how they behave in game or
out of game piss you off
but they're still damn good at what they
do in other words
these are the esports villains we all
secretly cheer for
here are the top 10 esports teams or
players you love to hate
opening up our list is melee's bad boy
leffen
now leffen can be as abrasive as he is
amazing at smash
if he doesn't like someone he'll make it
very clear
uh the saying that like there's two
kinds of people in this world hbox fans
of people who met him
and his tendency to criticize anything
and everything has made leffen a
polarizing figure
obviously it's less rare i would say
that people are an [ __ ] for fun
but i do think i i am actually kind of
allowed to say that
i am an [ __ ] for the people and
leffen's love for melee and its
community is second to none
sure his words may be harsh when it
comes to other competitors but he also
doesn't hold back
when it comes to the health of his game
either again i am not for a puff fan
it is a reality right that like if
all i wanted to do was just win yeah i
would probably pick puff
you know what i'll i'll play the most
boring character for that much money i
don't want to do that
and fans love him and respect him for
that but whether you're a die hard fan
or a hater
it's impossible not to be in awe of
leffen's play
they don't call him the god slayer for
nothing armada has no shield
absolutely tearing through everyone
early call of duty esports was a wild
time with teams sitting so close to each
other at tournaments
trash talking ran rampant
but no group of players better define
this era of cod
than the core roster of firico impact
who come in at number nine on our list
impact might have been a collection of
cod's most toxic pros
but they were the best and they let
everybody know it they even got
into it with the fans you watch the game
i play the game i win i win
impact were a little intense to be sure
but they gave viewers a show unlike any
other team
matches were as entertaining for their
trash talking as they were for what
actually happened in game
and damn if it wasn't fun to watch it's
gonna be in the eyes of parasite again
here let's see he's been just
he you know he's he's been struggling
this game here picks up a nice kill
and now i'm gonna try to pick up another
oh
boom parasite with that swag look at the
reaction look at the reaction
he's just trying to say look how easy
that is
number eight on our list is everybody's
most loved most hated blue-haired
fortnite legend
ninja this guy's rise to stardom was
nothing short of astronomical
going from your everyday streamer to the
biggest name in gaming
and with that rise came the haters
off what the [ __ ] you say to me you
little [ __ ]
how are you how are you not in [ __ ]
school huh
or his questionable attempts at dance
instruction
come on baby show me what you got don't
do it just move if you gotta throw it
just move so i want to see some movement
i'm not seeing enough movement
oh my god but no amount of cringe-worthy
clips can take away from the
millions of fans who helped push ninja
to the top making him a gaming icon that
legitimately
managed to transcend streaming
[Applause]
g2 esports head up the seventh spot on
our list as both the villains
and the heroes of european league of
legends
so g2's relationship with european fans
used to be
complicated after winning their first
domestic title in 2016
g2 blew it at msi with their now
infamous
vacation i don't think they would get
gain much from screaming challenger
teams anyways
so yeah we screamed only these two days
in shanghai long story short players
chose to go on vacation instead of
practicing for that year's msi
what resulted was g2 going two and eight
at the tournament
which in turn lost europe their first
seed at the following
world championship fans were pissed at
g2
and their nonchalant attitude and the
org rolled with it branding themselves
as the villains of europe fast forward
to 2020 and g2 have become eu's saviors
bringing the region back to the top of
competitive league with their 2019
msi win this is what peak league of
legends looks like
and it comes from europe a world
record g2 esports 3-0
will win msi 2019.
they're league of legends most memeable
team they have as many haters as they do
fans and they have a lot and i mean a
lot
of fans i'm talking about none other
than tsm
but more specifically tsm fans who land
at number six
on our list
[Applause]
as almost always csn chance like
currently the loudest for the longest
time tsm were the kings of north
american league of legends
as one of the oldest and most successful
teams in the scene they grew
one of the biggest and most infuriating
fan bases
in all of esports it appears that we
have a uh
well tsm fan in the audience that's
weird because i don't know what tsm
would be doing out of finals they've
never made it past
week two anyway uh hello uh apparent tsm
fan
uh what do you think of your team this
year
well that just about sums up tsm fans
but if there's anything you can take
away from the tsm fans it's their
dedication to their team
bandwagoners aside tsm jerseys flood any
arena the team's playing in
and sometimes ones they're not we've got
that
coming in here as both of the jewel
lanes start on the bottom side
[Applause]
at number five we have fgc legend
filipino champ
filipino
[Music]
this dude is the definition of bad
mannered and in game can sometimes be a
bully
he'll toy with his opponent before he
takes them out leave him alone
damn he is turning it out the crowd is
loving it right now no they're not
you know what's actually funny about
this is that champ is not even doing
anything else he could ground him when
he jumps and actually mess up his
approach but he's just letting him move
forward and then pushing it back it's
just being a bully
and out of game well let's just say that
f champ isn't afraid to say
what's on his mind oh does that go suck
he does
he does i told you
i can't really a lot of bad words in the
stream right now because i gotta act it
you know i gotta act professional but
i got him pregnant you know what i mean
i got diego pregnant dog
but damn does he put butts in seats with
f champ
fans know they're gonna get an
entertaining match full
of trash talking and bm sure he's a heel
but he embraces it and people love to
watch heels
dude i love the haters actually oh guys
please keep on booing me
and keep following my twitter you all my
haters follow me on twitter
youtube facebook they try to search for
me on any sort of like platform so shout
outs to all my haters i love you guys
yeah keep hating i need more money
at number four is the grim reaper of
dota eternal envy
in his quest to be the best envy's never
been afraid to kick his teammates
if there's even a chance his team could
improve and while some of those
unceremonious removals turned out fine
others were much more messy
post the ac eternal envy has kicked both
svg and i
from the team i'm not really gonna go
into much details about it
in this video but what i will say is it
wasn't a very
peaceful exit i think it's kind of
personal between us
i think envy doesn't like me i don't
know about everyone else but that's how
i feel at least on the team
that's how i felt on the last team but
despite all the roster drama it's
impossible to deny the positive effect
he's had on north america whether it's
envy leading cloud 9 to a string of top
placings in 2014
or winning the shanghai major in 2016 he
has always given na a place
at the top of dota i mean without envy
we wouldn't even have no tidehunter's
infamous
level 1 roshan bait
the bait is lame there's a small blood
patch where admiral [ __ ] it's just
happy and it is actually a trap because
they came to check for it
now they're stunned it goes out of mouth
they're gonna bring it down
oh my james now on the penis
the swedes they pull something out of
the bag and feeders gonna go
down as well oh no time hunter
what a stop what a strategy coming out
from eternal envy
third on this list is fnatic's legendary
2015 cs go roster
this iteration of fnatic made history in
2015.
they were the first team ever to win
back-to-back majors in cs go
and fnatic star player olofmeister
looked shall we say
head and shoulders above everyone else
for fans of high-level cs go
there was no better team to watch but
with the good
came controversy starting with rumors
about flusha allegedly cheating
um i know that a couple of my teammates
are convinced
that they think they cheat then there's
the fiasco and resulting controversy
that was the olaf boost at dreamhack
winter all of meister is still waiting
the patience game coming i can spot them
coming out of the street door as well
he's here
he sees them down there straight
headshot they have no idea
smith's looking confused and dazed and
there's gonna be a follow-up
shut up you've gotta be kidding me take
stock here
shimmer as well oh it finally works and
now fnatic if this is the comeback
moment for them
it wasn't fair against llc it was a
dirty trick in my opinion
yeah needless to say fans were pissed
fnatic were flooded with so much hate
after the forfeited match
and some of them thought about early
retirement i was
like i was kind of considering because
it was like such a low low point i mean
i have had much hate through
through the whole career pretty much in
cs go on
but this this thing was just like it was
so much at the same time
and it was very very hard for for me as
well as the others
taking the runner-up spot on our list is
one of esports greatest trash talkers
idra like many other players on this
list idro was never afraid to speak his
mind
if he thinks you're boosted you can be
sure he's going to let you know
this guy's pretty bad this guy's just
bad i see this guy's terrible
he's terrible this guy's actually awful
he's just awful all right what do you
think about cruncher and how do you
think this match is gonna go
i'm playing really bad but it's more
than enough to beat him
[Music]
he'd spam the chat tilt off the face of
the earth in pro games his salt levels
were so high at one point
he rage quit a pro game he was about to
win
thanks to units that weren't even real
the void race all hallucinations doing
absolutely
no damage whatsoever there's the blink
up onto the high ground just trying to
distract
idra those hallucinated void rays almost
fully charged wheat
and idra left the game
oh now wheat
when i first played brood or someone
said wouldn't it be funny if you
hallucinated a bunch of carriers and
your opponent just left that is what we
just saw here at mlg but at the end of
the day idris bm was a testament
to how much he cared about starcraft his
trash talk
started and ended in the game idra was a
classic case of a player
who was just too passionate about the
game he loved
of course after years without a working
computer the dude is mellowed out
just a little bit no i haven't owned a
functioning desktop in like two years
now
oh my god really uh yeah
okay no i i was just a really
competitive person and starcraft
happened to be the competition that
stuck
but no the starcraft was just a way to
beat people
and
topping off our list we have the master
of jigglypuff the most hated character
in super smash brothers melee
that's right we're talking about none
other than hungrybox
there are few things more irritating to
melee players than jigglypuff
the character's slow grindy playstyle
promotes rage inducing strategies
and don't even get us started on rest
small stage now the blast zones
definitely favor captain falcon
oh open randall
[Music]
folks did you just see did he know
hungrybox mastered
all of these annoying techniques and
reached the top of competitive melee
because of it
and some fans hate it by our
everybody says what are you gonna do why
would you throw something
not to mention that back in the day hbox
had a bit of a bad rep outside the game
too
if you knew the things i heard if you
knew
the the amount of [ __ ] that i get for
being me
but watching hungrybox fall to his knees
crying tears of joy after winning evo
fans can't help but feel proud of the
guy and appreciate
all the hard work he's put in over the
years sure his main is
unbelievably frustrating to play against
but hungrybox's climb to the top of
melee
is inspiring you know my my dad just
passed away
you know it was my biological dad and we
i know his personal stuff but he told me
you'll never be the best you'll be good
but you'll never be the best
so i hope he sees me now because
i'm sorry man no no it's fine it's
almost forgiven but it's
it's a lot of closure for me he's
someone who some fans
hate but admire he may be a jigglypuff
mane but he's also the best player
in melee and you can't help but look up
to the champ
right guys that's it for this top 10 and
you know what to do if you loved it
or you hated it comment below like the
video and sub to the channel
and i'll see you next time now you know
who got the whole
love to hate mentality down pat
that is pro wrestling think about all
the heels
in pro wrestling history that you love
to hate
ted dibiase nwo
stone called steve austin dx to a degree
dave batista rowdy roddy piper
hulk hogan at one point randy savage
ric flair terry funk
um kenny omega
who else who else who else